Herzlich willkommen zum Dicke Bretter Podcast. Wir sind ein Podcast von Constanze Kurz, Elisa Lindinger und Elina Eichstedt und sprechen über Policy im weitesten Sinne, nämlich meistens was dahinter steckt, was die Prozesse sind und machen das immer anhand von aktuellen Beispielen. In unserer allerersten Folge waren wir schon mal bei der UN und die UN ist ein großes Thema, deswegen wollen wir heute auch nochmal über die UN sprechen und ich bin heute hier mit Constanze Kurz. Und Tanja Fahratala von EP Center Works. Und bevor wir jetzt loslegen mit diesen Policy-Themen, wollen wir noch einmal unsere Gästin, Tanja, vorstellen. Ich hab's eben schon gesagt, sie kommt von EP Center Works. Das ist eine Digital Rights NGO aus Österreich, der oder die ein oder andere mag sich schon kennen, vielleicht von Netzneutralitätsthemen und auch häufig in Personen von Thomas Lohninger. Aber es gibt noch mehr wundervolle, fleißige Policy-Menschen bei EP Center, nämlich zum Beispiel die Tanja. Tanja, magst du dich vielleicht einmal selber vorstellen, mal erzählen, was dich zu EP Center verschlagen hat und was du sonst noch so machst?
Ich würde dich eigentlich nochmal, du hast ganz am Anfang mal gesagt, dass du auf Deutsch kaum über diese ganzen Verhandlungen zur Konvention gesprochen hast. Also ich denke, du hast ein bisschen geschädert, was die Klangpunkte sind durch den Prozess. Würdest du dir das manchmal wünschen oder ist es auch so, dass du dir vorstellen könntest, es würde auch stören, wenn jetzt plötzlich auf bestimmte Aspekte in den Verhandlungen sich eine große Öffentlichkeit stürzen würde. Also könntest du da eine Meinung zu sagen?
Was jetzt zu der Frage, ob man mehr Öffentlichkeitswirksamkeit brauchen sollte für diese Punkte?
Ja, du hast eben erklärt, diese informellen Gespräche, die haben kein Protokoll, denn da geht es ums Fleisch. Und wir haben ja nur bei vielen Verhandlungen, da wird Kalé sicherlich auch sagen können, gerade so bei der Chatkontrolle gesehen, plötzlich dringt da eine Öffentlichkeit ein, da wird es interessant, aber auch skandalisiert teilweise. Also würdest du dir das manchmal eher wünschen oder glaubst du, das ist vielleicht auch ganz cool, dass diese ganzen Verhandlungen, nicht nur informellen, sondern auch die ad hoc committee sessions, wie sie stattfinden, eigentlich unter dem Radar der Öffentlichkeit sind. Also was hat Vor- und Nachteile für dich?
Ich würde mir wünschen, natürlich zu diesen Informals auch zutritt zu haben. Also ich denke, dass je öffentlicher umso besser. Man muss dazu sagen, die Verhandlungen, so wie sie jetzt sind, werden immer wieder von anderen Organisationen, die häufiger auf UN-Ebene tätig sind, als Gold Standard bezeichnet. Weil es absolut nicht üblich ist, bei der UN dann auch tatsächlich die Zivilgesellschaft eingebunden zu haben. Also dementsprechend, wir sind uns absolut bewusst, dass das schon mal ein großer Schritt ist, so wie es jetzt ist. Nichtsdestotrotz natürlich, Öffentlichkeit und Zugang zu den Informationen betreffend die informellen Gruppen sind wirklich wichtig. In Wahrheit bekommt man den halt nur dann, wenn man sich mit Staatenvertretern bei einem Kaffee in der Pause unterhält und mal nachfragt. Beziehungsweise wenn es eben diese Informationsrunden gibt. Und die waren jetzt, in New York hatten wir genau eine und die hatten uns im Nachhinein dann wurden wir informiert, wie jetzt der Stand der Dinge war. Und von den anderen Gruppen erfährt man dann am Schluss im Plenum, was da ausgehandelt wurde, aber man hat keine Ahnung, wie und was und wer. Im Allgemeinen muss ich schon dazu sagen, ich würde mir für den gesamten Verhandlungsprozess sehr viel mehr Öffentlichkeitswirksamkeit wünschen. Ich glaube es ist sehr wichtig, auch für die breite Öffentlichkeit, sich dessen bewusst zu sein, dass diese Verhandlungen gerade laufen. Dass diese möglicherweise jetzt im Winter zu einem Abschluss kommen werden. Auch wenn das möglicherweise jetzt sehr optimistisch gedacht ist. Man weiß es nicht. Und dass es tatsächlich Auswirkungen haben kann und vor allem auch, sage ich jetzt mal an alle Journalisten, die vielleicht hier zuhören. Das kann auch Meinungsfreiheitsfragen betreffen und zwar sehr leicht. Also ich habe schon gesagt, es gibt hier Öffnungsklauseln. Es werden vermutlich Straftatbestände eingeführt werden, die schon auch das Potenzial haben, hier die Arbeit von Journalisten zu erschweren. Und man muss sich auch bewusst sein, dass das auch die schwammige Formulierung der aktuellen Core Cyber Crimes sind, die das Potenzial haben. Auch Good Faith Hackers, Journalisten, Aktivisten und so weiter einzubeziehen, deren Arbeit wirklich schwieriger zu machen. Und sie potentiell auch einer Strafverfolgungsgefahr aussetzen. Also mir wäre sehr recht, natürlich seitens der UN mehr öffentlichen Zugang zu haben, nämlich auch zu den Informals. Aber umgekehrt eben auch ist es wichtig, das Interesse und auch das Bewusstsein in der Öffentlichkeit zu schaffen, um diese Verhandlungen auch entsprechend zu verfolgen. Egal wie anstrengend jetzt vielleicht das UN Web TV sein kann. Aber es steht hier viel am Spiel.
Vielleicht um nochmal bei der Frage von Kranz so ein bisschen einzuhaken. Du hast jetzt gesagt, du hättest da gerne mehr Aufmerksamkeit. Wie ist es denn, ich sag mal, mit öffentlichkeitswirksamen Aktionen? Weitestgehend sitzen ja in der UN und auch in diesen Verhandlungen wahrscheinlich einfach Diplomaten, das sind Staatsbeamten. Wie würde denn so eine zivilgesellschaftliche Aufmerksamkeit, wie wir sie teilweise in der EU haben, überhaupt aussehen? Was ist da eigentlich effektiv? Also wir haben ja irgendwie schon ein paar offene Briefe und sowas gesehen. Aber ich finde es immer interessant und das ist ja auch so ein bisschen das, was wir hier versuchen, den Hörerinnen mitzugeben. Wann macht es eigentlich Sinn, mich als Bürgerin in diesen Policyprozess einzubringen? Und wann ist es sinnvoll da auch irgendwie rein zu grätschen? Und was muss ich da eigentlich tun? Und das würde mich bei der UN tatsächlich interessieren, einfach weil es ja am Ende schon die Mitgliedsstaaten sind, die da entscheiden. Und das wahrscheinlich auch irgendwie ein Stück weit von oben von der Bundesregierung kommt.
Genau, das ist es. Also ich habe jetzt nicht meine Abgeordneten, die ich gewählt habe, fürs EU-Parlament zum Beispiel direkt. Also ich habe hier kein Pendant auf UN-Ebene. Es stimmt, es sind Diplomaten bzw. Ministerienmitarbeiter, es sind Beamte, die hier handeln. Der Zugang, den wir bekommen jetzt als Zivilgesellschaft zu diesen Verhandlungen, ist wie gesagt offenbar die Ausnahme. Also es ist für uns das erste Mal, dass wir auf UN-Ebene tätig sind. Aber was ich von anderen Organisationen, die das regelmäßig machen, höre, ist, dass es wirklich Gold Standard ist. Also von dem her ja, schon mal ein erster Schritt. Aber natürlich mediale Aufmerksamkeit, wir haben das versucht wiederholt herzustellen. Also wir hatten eine Pressekonferenz in Wien. Ich habe dann, also eine physische in Wien, die dann auch, sie war beide, sie war physisch und online. Ich habe dann auch eine virtuelle moderiert für den spanischsprachigen Bereich, eben mit Partnerorganisationen, die hier als sie hier waren, eben aus den latinamerikanischen Ländern. Kolleginnen hatten auch in der letzten Session bei der UN, haben sie eine Pressekonferenz gehalten, aber ich selbst nicht am Panel. Aber da gab es in Kooperation mit dem US Press Service ein sehr gutes und auch sehr gut rezipiertes Pressegespräch. Diese Dinge haben gut funktioniert und laufen erst mal. Wir sind momentan auch dabei, verschiedensten Ländern, verschiedensten Ebenen auch Artikel, Op-Ed zu schreiben. Bei mir steht das noch vor Weihnachten an, auch. Wir versuchen über Blogposts zu informieren. Die Medienarbeit ist da natürlich sehr wichtig. Es ist wie gesagt schwierig für den Einzelnen, sich hier einzusetzen, weil man jetzt nicht die Möglichkeit hat, direkt mit Abgeordneten oder mit Parteien oder sonst was in Kontakt zu treten. Es sind wie gesagt Staatsvertreter, es sind die Regierungen, es sind Diplomaten, die hier handeln. Nichtsdestotrotz wäre es möglicherweise auch eine Idee, sich hier an die Behörden in den eigenen Staaten zu wenden.
Dann wollen wir doch mal diese mangelnde Öffentlichkeit gleich mal ein bisschen adressieren. Wir sind ja quasi Teil der Öffentlichkeit. Wir machen ein Podcast, der wird bei Chaos Radio erscheinen. Wir werden bestimmt auch diesmal wieder zumindest einen Teil des Gesprächs transkribieren. Der kommt dann bei netzpolitik.org.
Wunderbar, herzlichen Dank dafür.
Warte auf meine fiese Frage. Wir haben den Stand vom 27. November. Er ist noch relativ aktuell. Ich sage nochmal die Date, wir sind heute am 7. Dezember 2023. Wenn ich von dir erwarten würde, nenn mir mal die drei kritischsten Punkte, wo du unbedingt auch die Unterstützung einer kritischen Öffentlichkeit bräuchtest. Welche würdest du nennen für den aktuellen Stand?
Ich würde nennen, ein sehr eingeschränkter Anwendungsbereich für die Konvention. Nämlich wirklich nur zugeschnitten auf die Core Cyber Dependent Crimes. Also wirklich nur auf einen ganz engen Anwendungsbereich an Straftatbeständen. Und die müssen scharf formuliert sein. Die müssen ganz genau formuliert sein. Und hier darf es keinen Spielraum geben, insbesondere was die Formulierung angeht. So wie die Vorsatzformulierungen im Moment sind, beziehen sie ethische Hacker, Journalisten und Aktivisten mit ein. Also es kann nicht ausgeschlossen werden, dass die auch unter Strafe gestellt werden. Das zweite, was ich mir wünschen würde, sind stärkere, umfassendere Safe Guards. Wenn man sich die Konvention im Moment ansieht, so muss man feststellen, dass die einzelnen Teile, in Österreich würden wir so sagen, ein bisschen zusammengeschustert, wirken und man keinen roten Faden hat, was jetzt Safe Guards tatsächlich anwendbar sind. Welche es gibt, welche anwendbar sind, das sind sehr generische, sehr breite Formulierungen. Es braucht ganz konkrete Vorgaben, welche Mindestmaße an Sicherheitsmaßnahmen. Es gibt gerade einen Hinblick auf die sehr weitreichenden, sehr stark eingreifenden Überwachungsmechanismen und das auch noch in Kooperation mit der Möglichkeit, hier Rechtshilfe begehren zu stellen. Das ist sehr wichtig. Ich würde mir eine sehr viel stärkere Datenschutzbestimmung wünschen.
Ist das schon Punkt 3?
Das kann man hier noch zu Punkt 2 sehen. So wie sie hier momentan formuliert ist, ist sie schwammig, sie stellt auf nationales Recht ab und sie ist absolut nicht tauglich, entsprechenden Schutz unserer Daten sicherzustellen. Punkt 3. Im Allgemeinen ein Einschränken der möglichen Überwachungsmechanismen, die es hier gibt. Insbesondere keine Echtzeitüberwachung und eine Klarstellung, dass nichts in die Richtung eines Aufweichens von Verschlüsselung oder des Zulassens durch die Hintertür von Spyware gelesen werden darf. Es gibt viele Punkte, aber ich würde mir diese drei jetzt mal wünschen.
Naja, dass du diese drei nennst, deutet ja darauf hin, dass da noch viel mehr kommen könnte, aber dass das die schlimmsten sind. Ich finde es schon mal gut, alle schon so ein bisschen angesprochenen Punkte noch mal priorisiert zu haben.
Ich bin sie da rein nach dem Aufbau der Konvention durchgegangen. Ich finde sie alle gleichwertig. Ich kann nicht sagen, dass eine ist wichtiger als das andere. Tatsächlich nicht.
Also liebe Tanja, vielen Dank erst mal dafür, dass du uns diese Auskunft gegeben hast, weil ich glaube, es gibt einfach sehr wenige Menschen auf der Welt, die sich so intensiv damit beschäftigen und sozusagen, ja, einen Einblick geben. Wir wollen natürlich unser Möglichstes tun, diese mangelnde Öffentlichkeit vielleicht auch herzustellen, nicht wahr?
Genau, und vielleicht versuchen wir dann noch mal rauszufinden, wer in Deutschland dafür zuständig ist. Wahrscheinlich sind das irgendwelche Menschen im Auswärtigen Amt, würde ich jetzt mal vermuten.
Es gibt sogar eine Liste, man kann sich die konkreten Namen...
Dann würde ich sagen, wir verlinken diese Liste mal und dann werden sie uns alle hassen.
Also ich fand es erstaunlich, dass die alle namentlich genannt sind, auch aus allen Ländern. Also auch die namentlichen Vertreter.
Ja, es ist spannend, wie transparent, intransparent dieser ganze Prozess ist und was dann öffentlich ist und was nicht, aber können ja vielleicht die Zuhörerinnen mal drüber nachdenken, ob sie sich da nicht doch noch engagieren wollen, weil dann, ich glaube, bei den Punkten, die Tanja genannt hat, da brauchen wir uns dann fast keine Gedanken mehr über einen Hackerparagrafen machen, was uns da graut. Das ist deutlich schlimmer wahrscheinlich.
Es hat Potential für schlimmeres, ja.
Genau. Erstmal vielen Dank, Tanja. Schön, dass du da warst.
Herzlichen Dank euch.
Vielleicht darfst du dich auch irgendwann noch mal mit was anderem beschäftigen. Wir sind gespannt.
Doch, das wird kommen, ja, natürlich.
Oder wir reden mal darüber, wie Policies in Österreich eigentlich entstehen, um dann die ganzen Menschen komplett zu verwirren. Wir wünschen euch einen schönen Kongress, glaube ich, an dieser Stelle. Wir sehen uns wahrscheinlich auch auf dem Kongress. Der 37C3 findet dieses Jahr nämlich wieder in Hamburg statt. Und ganz vielleicht wird es da auch noch eine kleine dicke Bretterüberraschung geben, aber das ist noch nicht so ganz klar.
Da sprechen tun wir nichts, wir versuchen nur.
Ja, das mit dem Bohren ist halt auch nicht so einfach. In Saal 1 geht das bestimmt auch wieder nicht. Genau. Vielen, vielen Dank fürs Zuhören. Wie immer werden wir bestimmt den Text auf Netzpolitik jetzt, je nachdem, wie schnell wir sind, parallel oder nachreichen, vielleicht auch noch so die eine oder andere Sache verlinken. Und ich würde, glaube ich, schließen mit, beschäftigt euch mehr mit UN-Gesetzgebungen. Weil New York und Wien ist eigentlich ganz nett, kann ich sagen.
Dann vielen Dank Tanja. Und wir hören uns hoffentlich bei dicke Bretter 6 im Jahr 2024.
Bis dann.
Ciao, ciao.